broke your heart you think in y'all's
life you think who is somebody hey
everybody's had their hearts broke huh
who and nobody wants a shade on them I'm
just saying who did it who done it
sometimes it just happens when thing you
follow up you know you did it to
yourself sometimes you know but just
saying who did it to y'all feel you got
so you want to say I broke my own heart
a million times I'm saying who broke
y'all [ __ ] you [ __ ] creeps okay cuz
this is obviously hard your heart broke
yeah but not by a girl that I was dating
I had a crush on my best friend before a
long time ago okay that's what younger
and what happened and she liked me at
the time but I didn't know she liked me
Wow so waited a year to ask her huh
and what happened when you went off to
war yeah that was like my biggest crush
ever and then uh so she didn't feel the
same way after that and then capitalized
but there's we became friends still
friends today all right and if she
married now she's married and do you
guys wear it to a judge she's an
attorney
oh where I don't say where he's coast I
I mean there was there was a senior girl
Maggie hide who I really love sit have
after as a sophomore but but yet and I
can't really say she broke my heart we
got really flirty one night in college I
thought was gonna happen but just my
clothes I'd go back to this town
sometimes they had a girl that I was in
love with when I was a child and then
something I saw her in college once she
broken up with her boyfriend and we like
hung out a couple times that I was like
too nervous to try and like know if like
she was interested in me I was like like
I'm like I was just like I would just
spent all my money on like new shoes for
that night or whatever and [ __ ] like I
just had still no ability to talk like
no matter how much new shoes I put on
them just couldn't be like do you want
to touch my body
he's a zebra anyway yeah man this chick
Sarah I I had one
had one tick when I first got to LA she
was so bad of course yeah any dude she
wanted
I thought we're like in a relationship
and then I saw hot I was like hang out
tonight she's like oh I can't my girls
birthday oh my god makes sense and then
I see on TV she was like in stripper
relationship with like some famous dude
how's it go well I don't stand a [ __ ]
chance city man dead broke me I can't
compete with that
that's right and then when I text about
Jason
I call her out if I couldn't speak I
think of each of the TV lights all
around right teams here's some [ __ ] I'm
like what's up with this and she goes
what did you think was gonna happen I
like oh oh
frozen bro that's ice cold Craig yeah a
girl showed up outside my work right
after we broke up with another dude and
I chased them in my car were you working
at Trader Joe's oh yeah
how did you get let go up from there you
did I farted on my manager as a joke and
I filmed it and I put it on Instagram
and it was viral and in corporate saw
and they're like get this kid a D oh
damn get him out of here what do you
mean get this advertising guru this is
marketing genius you're the only person
had liner that called me you know that
oh I was yeah oh I see if I was all
right
oh right man what happened recently yeah
oh wow yeah last year oh damn dude
people lose their jobs all the time and
he has no idea of America works or
anything happens you don't get it but I
don't know his last year yeah it was the
best thing that ever happened it should
be I should tell you sorry God yeah yeah
sorry you worked at tu for a long time
11 years yeah you're here 11 years bro
you do a solid bro you guys like the
Gandalf of traitors
you like the Philip Rivers of Trader
Joe's so I'm just gonna leave man yeah I
know I wanted I was too big of a [ __ ]
and then and then it happened and then
you you were guilty for it cuz you you
shout me out you remember you did a
story and you just followed Craig for
behind the scenes Trader Joe's oh and I
was fired like a week or two later
oh yeah you call me like hey man I have
anything to do with that is he blasted
it out more yeah but this was before the
gay before the gassing of the man yeah
yeah but still it all contributes to the
hyper like now I got to put on the show
yeah you really let one go on the
manager like a trip did he deserve it
yeah oh yeah it's your friend he laughs
he didn't give a [ __ ] about it but
corporate corporate huh my manager that
fired me went to my show Saturday and
then fired me Tuesday like he was the
homie he didn't give a [ __ ] it was like
like a Mice and Men when Lenny snuffs
out his brother you know he was like
almost crying I was like they did you
what you gotta do yeah they did yeah
remember the last day did you were you
on shift and then they told you to leave
they talked to me and then they uh they
talked to me I went back to work and
then they they said I just went back I
clocked out and they're like we'll let
you know if you need to come in tomorrow
and then the next morning I went in and
they're waiting at the door I was like
oh [ __ ]
like you guys made me wake up this early
gonna called me you know but it was a
blessing right it was it my career start
poppin off after that Wow she fell
you've had your heart broke yeah but a
lot of it was mine yeah did you heard
any of his story a lot of it was my
fault no it seems like I used to I used
to be like they do that was just like
like I didn't even need to know a girl
if I just liked her I just asked her out
immediately because I thought that's how
it worked you know yeah that's all black
guys things it works and that's why they
do so well with it most the girls yeah
yeah brother you know work for me you
wouldn't live a day in a white man's
[ __ ] brain bro it's so hard to ask a
girl out bro
it's impossible
I struggled scary like I said yes first
girlfriend just strong arm huh yeah but
the truth is you holding her up you know
you got ladies right there that's when
he asked you out anyone go out with me
yeah you're building a trust building
the trust that dress
[Music]